unusual competence is actually i love
applied mathematics it's my passion i
was doing ai neural networks when i was
back in university a long time ago and
it was the ai winter and so there was
always this passion about doing fun
thing and creating new algorithms stuff
like this so combine the two and you get
a lot of the dna of institute which is
doing deep tech innovation being a legal
ai but a different kind of leader a
leader actually coming from the
developing world and building a bridge
to the developed world which is a
concept at the time when we started
didn't exist people did not believe we
can do deep tech innovation starting
from africa people laughed at me so we
were talking about like don't try to
ride the wave ideally you create your
own wave that's how you need to think
about it if something is too fashionable
etc
think like a crypto 2022 until a recent
crash
it's probably a bit too late to join the
way from that point of view when things
get completely you know out of fashion
etc or now we're getting to crypto
winter that's an interesting time to
think about it you know when it's super
hype and stuff definitely not this thing
but follow your heart and grow where you
have amazing competence so now a
question for you actually what is your
unique skill
i mean my
you know like as i'm growing i'm
starting to understand this more and
more
and
so my skill is very very correlated with
my uh
with my rising when i was uh actually i
started recording at like uh 13 or 14
years old and from 13 to 19 i was mostly
learning by myself well i'm gonna learn
c plus plus i'm gonna see sharp and i
did this for like six or seven years and
when i remember
now i'm like this is a really really
important skill which is the learn curve
the learning curve that i have which is
really really compelling
and i think this is one of the skills
that i have particularly and i emphasize
a lot at my country which is what's your
learning curve and what's your speed of
learning um we don't hire for example we
don't hire for the the the culture we
have is
it's not really about hiring the
smartest people at the time sometimes
it's really hard it's really about
hiring people with the highest learning
curve people who are willing to learn
really fast and willing to adapt so
that's the skill really i learned how to
develop and actually building a company
with zero like company experience i was
like dealing with a lot of things that i
never did before like hiring the team
managing the team fundraising my
investors and
building product building for users
managing tech pre-go my code i was
basically building
ios games and i was basically coding
that's the only product skill that i had
so that's the first thing learning
curves and your capability to learn
skills uh the second
skill which is i was lucky enough to
to hide your experiences in a different
ecosystem uh in silicon valley and get
like a really really high exposure on
what was happening back in 2014 2015 and
2013 in a very mature ecosystem in in
palo alto in silicon valley and that i
saw
i saw 19 years old kids and 20 years old
students that were building companies
and were raising funds and raising
millions and me as like as a 19 years
old as a 16 years old 17 year old coming
from a small city in tunisia
and going to silicon valley and meeting
20 years old students building companies
raising millions launching products
that's really really life-changing for
you that will change your whole
perspective about the limits that you
have uh something we don't think about
as you know i never thought about
building a company when i'm in high
school or i never thought about building
for users when i was in high school it
was until i got that kind of exposure uh
to people with the same level of uh
skills and expertise as building
companies so i was lucky enough to get
that exposure that i think it's really
really important and i think now we have
the responsibility to give that exposure
for either students for other high
school students for other uh people who
want to learn lunch companies so i think
i had a lot of exposure from different
ecosystems really really young
early on and this learning curve
learning skill
thing yeah
these are the two things that i can
really recall so
as well basically you are one of the
best in the world in terms of
understanding you know this
educational system here but also having
a very early stage exposure in silicon
valley and you are coding yourself you
are doing it yourself which is another
aspect which is like the technical
aspect and you see like basically
launched go my code on his strengths you
know and it's a bit like the same for me
and what you're talking about like speed
of learning et cetera in the early days
of insta deep i basically we learned
everything in ai and uh for you know a
year
basically went back to school you could
say and took all the classes that they
could take on ai etc you know i had
studied it before
but i essentially learnt everything very
quickly and we built myself into an
expert so you have to be competent to be
able to do that but you see how you're
really pulling on your strengths if you
want to get to a good outcome and i
think this is important the notion that
hey i'm going to do a project just
because i think it's the right moment or
so then you think like it's an
opportunistic thing this will definitely
not work when you're pulling on strength
and
comparative advantages like you had i
don't think there are many young
tunisians who had a chance to be in
silicon valley at an early age and
iterate and then come back and stuff you
see like this is when you have an
opportunity because you're doing
something which others are not doing it
was the same for us we were doing uh
innovation in ai in tunis in 2015 2016
when it was still
science fiction for people so you have
to have that mentality that i'm doing
something
where people definitely do not
understand the opportunity or are not
doing it for whatever reason but i'm
also extremely competent at what i do so
in a sense if someone comes to tell us
hey your idea is dumb
you could actually listen to that person
first because maybe maybe it is but
you're probably as competent as that
person if not more like if somebody
comes to lecture me about
uh top talent in deep tech indonesia
and he's from europe or the us i
probably know that better because this
is my this was my life this is all my
friends i know them i have a better
opinion myself so you're on solid ground
the same way you answering ground when
you're talking about like education and
uh you know building a model that works
and seeing
from firsthand so i hope that gives you
a sense of what it takes if for whatever
reason the project that you're trying to
launch
doesn't have those
capabilities those assets and those
assets is there you're passionate you're
extremely competent i like the fact that
you mentioned your coding because i was
coding too like the first air engineer
of insta deep was me and zohara was
coding to to two tech founders and she
was doing the software part the ux the
web the design of products i was doing
like the science hardcore ai part and
and so
if you are competent you're passionate
and you have a differentiated
experience and point of view in your
project
you're already like filling in some of
like the key
i'd say
requirements to get started but then
again the the next one which is really
important is about the people you do it
with and this is another point i want to
emphasize
startup is not so much about the exact
idea
because the idea will iterate all the
time and you know you're probably
starting with the wrong idea but it's
your ability to iterate it's like the
general field is your field of
competence but exactly how you do it
what are the exact definition of the
project this can change a little bit and
it's more about people so if you're
thinking about like co-founders and
stuff
you have to
do it with people you really feel
super at ease with
you know yeah so yeah yeah i mean um one
of the the best thing about hiring of
some elven you actually can google it uh
some admin on hiring is
he said like three things about hiring
like uh
they usually like how do you hire people
right first are they smart
second do they get things done and the
third one is like do i wanna work with
them or not but first the co-founders
before hiring first tell us about the
co-founders like it has to be long-term
right
so
it's um
we always say that like it's not
necessarily a marriage but it is with
your co-founder
uh
hiring people could not be a marriage
but like having a co-founder it is
really really very very close to what a
marriage would look like exactly the
same like you will really need to manage
the relationship not just um
professionally but like this guy's going
to spend at least 15 hours a day with
you so you need to be really really at
ease working with them there should be
like a lot of trust a lot of
transparency
it's really really strong value system
between both or it doesn't gonna work
like 85 percent of companies i think
eighty percent of the companies they
died
number one reason is companies
co-founders dispute they die because
co-founders are not uh on east lake
that's why eighty percent of companies
they die because of co-founders dispute
so it's not running out of money it's
not uh product it's not users it's
co-founded so it's really and and your
co-founder is your brother so my
co-founder is my brother and it helps to
have a
um a co-founder as a brother because
there would be like they're already like
a base of trust and uh understanding and
even though usually when we think about
our brothers or sisters
you know we think oh we are completely
opposite right like we don't say like
i'm like my brother i'm like sister
usually there is a big difference
between brothers and sisters but that
could be also very very resourceful and
very helpful that you don't have
necessarily you don't necessarily share
the same view on product or users or ups
or and that can really lead to a lot of
great things um so yeah and and for me
like like it's not a coincidence at all
that go my code is successful and the
two you you two are brothers because
brother means here like really it is
about the trust like you said and it's
the same thing for me and my co-founder
zohar asleem
you know initially we met in something
completely unrelated it was in uh
tatooine actually i was doing a project
for
like
sports and leisures trying to help the
youth i was looking for someone to do my
website nothing to do with like elite ai
startup in the world right
just one thing
zora was an amazing person and she is an
amazing person like she is so
professional she works so hard and she's
such a nice person like the mix of
competence but trust and values
i felt strongly we had really the same
values
we really clicked and we were working at
like until 2 30 a.m on like the website
of the of the of the stadium it's called
academy at the time so she was like as
hardcore as me and i was like okay this
this feels right i told zora let's open
a tech company and she's like but to do
what i like i have no clue but i feel
good about it
and that's exactly how it should start
you feel good about it it's like you
your brother you know you know each
other very well each one has his own
strength it feels good we can do
something this is like this we can take
on the world yeah that's the mentality
and if you don't have that it will fail
very quickly because relationship
between founders is exactly a marriage
like you said it will get tested and of
course the test will come at the worst
possible time and let me share two tests
we had
zora and i and to show you like the
strength of the relationship we've built
and insta deep would not be where it is
without the strength of the relationship
between the the two co-founders it's
like first test we were starting to get
some traction at the time mradip was
very young we were 2000 late 2015
probably had like eight employees
and then zohara gets an offer from
silicon valley
from actually one of our clients he says
hey zoro you are just amazing you know
come work with us great package dollars
silicon valley amazing
very tempting right yeah and she said no
and she comes to to see me and she's
like karim i said no and you know i
would really love to go but
we have a team i gave my word we're
doing this together so i will decline
the opportunity
you see like you want to have a founder
which has this kind of like moral
strength who's with you
till the end if you want yeah and
later on
in the early days of insta-deep i was
not the ceo
that's an interesting point at the time
we were more like a tech business and so
zoro was the ceo and when we really went
all in on ai which was
late 2015 2016
it really made sense for the company
that i am the ceo because i'm the driver
of deep tech hardcore innovation it's an
ai startup like who's going to go talk
to like
partners etc
and so zora made something a decision
which is very rare and think about it
like how like you see like you should
not have ego in these things yeah she
decided basically and we had a
conversation about it look std is going
to be an ai startup
you are the ai expert you're the driver
now you're the ceo
you see like how many co-founders would
accept something like this so you need
to really have a strong
trust in each other an ability to do
what's right for the company and let
your ego on the way
and ability to resist temptations but
think about it today insta-deep has
raised 100 million dollars series b it's
the biggest successory of ai from africa
it's a success story in tunisia and i
hope go my code would be also a huge
success story
like
all this would not have happened if
there was not this super strong bond and
trust between us
and you see this been challenged right
this those were hard challenges what
they had just described
and so in any sort of entrepreneurial
projects you will have those challenges
no actually
this is like such a great great case of
initially they started working together
at first on on a website on a project so
it actually helps
before like going on a venture with the
co-founder to start to work on on a
project
like a really simple project
without like any necessarily like a
commitment for a co-founder or like so
it actually helps to really test with
someone this is the relationship that's
the relationship and this is one of the
best advice we even we're like before
you hire anyone
do like a one week product with them do
a two days project do a one month
project if it works okay you can double
down on having them as a co-founder on
hiring them so actually it helps to have
a prior relationship with but
you should have a trust also yes this is
not going to come in a month like
ideally ideal situation for example for
you would be i've studied with someone
i know that person we were we were
working hard on you know like exams and
stuff
so i know that person is good and there
is trust and then yes we do a one-month
project it really clicks but yeah
ideally you have also yeah trust is like
you don't have trust since day one it's
something you build through time
it's really like a long process like uh
yeah it takes years it takes years to
build trust and it takes years also to
build some kind of understanding of how
the other person works and how do you
work and how do we find like a
compromise or an agreement or like a way
to make things happen together um yeah
so so you so you get the idea you know
yeah and here i again i want to
emphasize
go my code i believe will not be the
success story that it is today if you
are not such a good strong team of
co-founders with the trust but also
differentiated strengths yeah you know
you and your brother you're not the same
each one has his own strengths
same with me like ideal situation is
strong trust
differentiated skill set yeah like me
and zoro we don't do the same thing yeah
her skill set is not mine and vice versa
yeah ideally both technical yeah as well
yeah so you see like if you each time
you click on one of these uh yeah take
one of those uh like bullet point key
points yeah your project
is much stronger yeah and trust me
you're going to need all of these to
have a chance like it's not even to be
successful but like to have a chance
yeah and then it's like literally
years and years of
execution execution like very hard i
remember very well at instadeep
when we made our first uh our first
2000 dinners like revenue contract that
was a big deal for us at the time
first year i think we had total
maybe something like seven thousand
dollars of revenues
and what is funny is since then we've
been like essentially like doubling
tripling revenues every year
and that is how you need to think about
stuff also don't think linear because
that seven thousand dollars of the first
year they were
extraordinarily valuable yeah think
about it as i am making progress and i'm
gonna map my progress on a log curve so
you want the you don't want it to be
linear and log curves meaning you want
it to be exponential
and if you manage to get something going
which has exponential
potential
you're on to something yeah so
disregard the naysayers like the first
the first revenues you have
those are priceless and the ability to
iterate from that is priceless because
after that it is just a matter of just
upping the game all the time it's like a
snowball it starts rolling and growing
and uh actually i'd love to hear how you
did that so the first revenues the facts
about go my code we spent the first
three years bootstrapping from 2017 to
2020
bootstrapping as like we raised zero
money from investors or vc
so what does that mean is you usually
have one month of
cash burn so
if you don't make money this month the
next month you're gonna die
so we were constantly challenged about
the revenues that money will make
because if you don't make money this
month we will die
and we actually had a very very and we
were like you know we were not like just
like having the 20 students that we have
every
four weeks we were like let's have 40
let's have 60 let's open more locations
organically without any prior investment
and i remember like um in june 2018 it
was one of the hardest months and we
were we just opened two other locations
in susan fertas and the month we when we
started the month we had i think we had
two thousand dnr's in the bank account
and at the end of the month we had to
pay 80 000 dinners
so in in in four weeks you need to go
from two thousand to eighty thousand
so the level really of um
the level of the the intensity that the
the level of confidence and trust and
work that the team should have is really
really high so if you don't have people
who actually really believe into the
project if you don't have people that
actually can understand uh this really
well it's not going to happen so so that
was really really challenging and that
was one of the most challenging thing
that we could specifically the first
three years because we were always
running on a one-month runway one month
right away if you don't make money this
month we will die next month and yeah
this is and that was really intense
yeah there are i i didn't know about
this yeah it's very funny because it's
very similar to our own story we started
also as a bootstrap like company was
founded with five thousand dinners and
that's all the money we had for the
first three three years and a half it's
exactly the same situation and i
actually believe it's very interesting
here
it's it's very healthy to start as a
bootstrap
uh so basically very little money and
have that positive pressure to perform
like what you described it really echoes
on how things were they still are like
that sometimes in terms of pressure
but it's this notion that
bootstrap you have to execute all the
time and in a sense it forces you to
look at reality there is a difference
between reality and how you perceive it
in a bootstrap the difference is not
very far because you know if you don't
make the money you're gonna die so it's
gonna hit you like a truck very quickly
if you imagine now you start a project
you raised
a hundred thousand uh dollars or more
you immediately gonna start making much
more expensive mistakes and the dna of
the team will not be the same people
will come because you have money so
there will there will be a risk that the
employees that come are not mission
driven they're more like mercenaries
they're not driven by the mission and so
what you described and which is very
similar to us that's very interesting
point is you have to put the team in a
sort of like healthy danger zone with
there's very little money it's a
bootstrap we're iterating we're seeing
what works what doesn't etc it brings
the team together it creates the dna of
the company that later on
will radiate to the whole uh sort of uh
organization which becomes bigger
international so for me this is very
important part and maybe like a takeaway
for all of you is
in the early days
of your company
it actually pays to be a bootstrap
bootstrap yeah it's don't rush to raise
money
raise money raising money early could
actually kill your company it would
create the wrong culture the wrong set
of expectations and you're not exactly
sure about the business model well when
you're iterating as a bootstrap
essentially like you're making a lot of
mistakes but they're not costly and at
the same time there's really strong
positive pressure to bring the team
together so if you survive bootstrap
yeah yes it's exactly the same it was
like three years or something it's
exactly like
you survive that bootstrap
you actually have now a team a unit a
company
which is ready to take on the world and
now it's a time to start thinking about
like how do i raise money except yeah
actually bootstrapping can help to
funnel the energy that the company focus
because as a company you can do so many
things at the same time right you can do
partnerships you can do marketing you
can run operations you can hire people
you can through events you can build
other products bootstrapping will funnel
your energy will tell you what's really
important is
selling building selling building and
running this cycle so it actually helps
to bootstrap because it will really
really try to find all the energy and it
will give you like a strong perspective
on what's important to to grow or like
to survive which is usually not too many
things it's usually two or three things
a building for users selling
a building for the experience and hiring
good people building culture and you
know as
i think in the first three years what we
did was building for users uh selling
and building culture and hiring people
purely focusing on that and cutting all
of the other uh stuff
it's like you know you know war zone you
have the adrenaline rush your senses are
aware because you could die at any time
that is bootstrap yeah and i agree it
gives you extraordinary focus and
there's something also important
later on if the project is successful
you're going to be facing
difficult customers difficult investors
world-class vips having gone through the
pain of bootstrap you know i i i'll give
you as a personal thing for for many
years
i had imposter syndrome i always think
i'm not good enough so maybe that's why
i became very competitive because i
always think oh it's not good enough i
could be better and so i'm when i talk
to people i have a tendency like to
be afraid a little bit about what i'm
doing and how explaining it the
bootstrap experience like you took so
much pain it because you become how to
say you become legitimate because you
know that nobody's went through the same
pain as you
when you're talking about your business
there is a feel and a shine that
this is really genuine this guy is not
telling me stories to raise money which
means actually you could go and talk to
anyone like you know and the best in the
business and you will feel like you're
one of them and that is also very
important you know like investors they
sense like uh you know is this for real
or not so
the genuine aspect of having really done
something very hard and original
innovative it will radiate in everything
you do
and that is a huge asset for future yeah
so i mean this is a huge asset for
investors but also for users it's
actually more credible to come to the
user and be like i did this and this and
this and i bootstrapped this then coming
to them and be like done nothing but
take my product or buy my service or
invest in my company it actually builds
a strong sense of credibility
two users two investors to your
employees to your employees as someone
who did and operated uh
through the years because you have to
lead by example at the end of the day if
you really want to build an
extraordinary business
you have to live and breathe the value
of this business you have to be the
example when it gets really really hard
you jump in in the trenches with the
team and you lead from the front you
know until you solve the problem you
need to have that vibe and it's much
easier to have it in bootstrap you know
so
so yeah one of the so i made like a
trillion mistake
while building on my code early early
days like i was 19 20 trying to build
like startups and i made like so many
mistakes and one of the major mistakes i
remember doing is
uh not necessarily funneling the energy
of focus early days
there is a big mistake i see a lot of
founders are doing is um
is trying to do what's really important
for a company at the company stage
a seed stage is really different from a
series b stage series stage you should
not be building for the company you
should be building for users series b
and serie c yes you may be building for
the company and less building for the
users as like seed stage you don't
necessarily need to put a lot of energy
and work into building processes and
building structure and building for the
company your energy should be really
about building for users listening to
users iterating on the product
cracking surviving surviving uh which is
like i meet a lot of founders just
starting the company and they're like i
don't have a hiring process or like i
don't know how to fundraise or i don't
know how to i don't have an office or
like i don't have i don't have a finance
team or like i don't have a business
plan or like i have no idea on
the the economics of my of my of my
company and i'm like dude what's the
product how many users what and what's
the generally feedback of these users on
the product and i think this is really
really critical is you need to learn
really to cut all of the noise around
the product and around the company and
really focus on what's going to make a
difference building for the users
building for the product listening to
users iterating and trying to sell and
trying to bring in more users that's the
only thing that you should do at least
the first one two three years i'd say
yeah yeah and and if you manage to do
this well
essentially you're
you're starting to have revenues coming
in and
revenue is actually an interesting and
customer feedback
this is an interesting signal that
you're in the right direction so if you
do this well after a few years
you're actually getting a more valuable
information from the market that
anything they would teach you in
business class or on how to run a
startup etc
i'm talking about your specific
positioning
product etc so because you see things
and you have the direct life feedback
and
your that feedback matters a lot to you
because you don't have any money anyway
so that revenue is really important you
will really learn and become super
competent
at what really matters which is
sometimes
different from what people say matters
so you have to you have that direct
learning expertise of course you know
general advice about how to run a
startup how to fundraise
definitely is going to be very useful
but i'm talking like when you're
iterating on a specific product on a
specific business positioning of your
company you
it's better to learn from what you see
than what people think should be the way
it gets done i'll give you an example
instead is
a leader in ai okay
for a long time everybody's like
coming to us why don't you do one
product you scale the product et cetera
because yes that's the startup playbook
everybody does that
but
me i kinda resisted this because i was
like what we're doing is different we're
actually a deep tech innovation company
so rather than we build all the product
directly and we try to sell them to
whoever
we created a system where we engage into
collaborations with elite partners some
of the best in the world
and we build a product together so it's
like innovation stage before product
is there a playbook for this honestly i
haven't found any but i don't care
because i know it works we're doing it
you see so this is what is important
like
you take advice you always
are willing to accept that maybe you're
wrong about something but also take
advice from reality you know
today with this approach instead deep is
you know a key ai partner to biontech
biontech is probably like one of the
most influential biotech companies on
earth having designed the covid vaccine
which is
the biopharmaceutical product most
successful in history
don't you think it's funny that their ai
partner and we're doing a lot of very
exciting stuff you know
is actually an ai bootstrap at a
tunisian bootstrap started with 5 000
dinners i think this tells you something
it tells you that
from tatamine yes it started in
tattooing yes
so it tells you something yeah it tells
you number one that you need to believe
that great success stories can happen
you know i was surprised sometimes i am
surprised by the quality of what we do
the amazing opportunities what we have
so a positive project will take you much
further with the exponential growth than
you would ever dream of but this also
tells you something is tunisia
in and sort of like the quality
education you've gotten and this is also
true for africa in general the the
the talents we have etc
we can really do something amazing in
this time because now is the time of
digital deep tech innovation
and actually this is exactly what gomer
code is doing in a funny way uh us we're
an innovation power hub but before
getting to an innovation power hub and
doing crazy stuff with ai
you need to get
the key digital skills to get there
and that's exactly what you guys are
doing this is funny yeah i mean this is
a really really good point which is you
don't necessarily need to play with the
books right or you don't need
necessarily to play with the standards
which is something i really really
struggled with as a first-time founder
which is i would have so much input
coming to me from all directions like
the people who never built companies
they will come and be like don't do this
to this or like the people who actually
built companies historically also in
tunisia would come and be like this is
not the right way so you need to process
a lot of input
from everywhere and one of the like most
important skills that you need to know
and like understand really early on is
you really really need to
articulate your own
decision-making and your own choices by
yourself which is really really hard to
do
when you're really young also
and one of the things i really remember
particularly when we
raised our pre-series eight we had a 650
000 usd we just raised
and we were like okay it's the year of
expansion we're gonna expand to other
countries
first person i remember talking to he's
like don't expand expand in tunisia you
know it's the second person i talked to
he was like just he was like just expand
in one country
the third person uh i've talked to he
was like
um
two countries it's a lot of countries
don't do then more two countries
so i actually had to come up and be like
we're going to seven countries and we're
gonna do it and the team they were like
no way we can do seven countries that's
a lot of countries to do with 650 000
usd during a pandemic
um so but we had really strong reasoning
that seven countries it's an important
number and you need to be at seven
countries and i can tell you if we did
not do seven countries would never raise
uh the eight million uh round that you
raised so you actually had to come up
and say no
to all of the people you have as like
you know telling you that don't launch
two countries don't launch from
countries
but assume the launch of seven countries
which is an incredible amount of work so
this is such a good um good point right
on like
the ability that you the ability that
you should have to take your own
decisions
and really learn from the ground because
i was really really convinced and i
really
truly believed by the product we were
building and by the technical aspect and
by the scalability aspect that was in
the product
that not everyone would understand that
like we use this knowledge graph and
there is a way for us actually to
control quality through these knowledge
graphs and this is how we should do it
but from an external point of view you
wouldn't understand that we could scale
education in seven countries or in eight
countries but because i was really
really convinced by the model and i've
seen it and i tried it on and i was
building the tag
basically i was extremely convinced by
the scalability of them so basically
don't think
the limits are where people say the
limits are
think about the limits are based on your
own experience and your own capability
and thinking about where they really are
and so if you have that mentality you
can really turn
potential opportunities into very big
ones uh i want to share one with you
which is uh you know you know the deep
learning in dubba is coming to tunisia
this summer
this plus ai hack which we are also
co-organizing uh like like in 2019 on at
the radius stadium and encourage all of
you to come and participate to the
machine learning competitions
the indaba the first in daba which was
we went to which was in south africa in
2018
we have this amazing opportunity and
this is why we're bringing it like we
lobbied hard to bring it to tunisia this
year we had this amazing opportunity to
meet
the best
ai researchers in the world
david silver the inventor of alphago
you know which
alpha zero which you heard about like
the game in chess and go like those
amazing ai systems
the leadership of google ai everybody
was there
and in particular with the deepmind team
they we start talking like tech et
cetera you know we're hardcore uh you
know researchers in ai
and they throw a problem at us they're
like uh yes i'm doing this but this
thing i haven't solved it and you know
we didn't have time but this is a
hardcore one stuff
okay
so
i come back to the team and say hey
actually this researcher was nando de
freitas is the leader of the machine
learning team of uh of deepmind he's one
of the key authors of the gaito
for those who follow ai deepmind built
an ai system that does 600 different
tasks robotics chat playing atari with
the same model and same parameters like
it's insane what's going on and so those
guys
i'm like hey nando actually
tell me about this problem and he said
this very hard and they haven't done on
it you know what we're gonna solve it
you see everybody was like no you're you
must be kidding like you know like this
is deep mind and but no no no i said he
opened the door here
you know what we're gonna crash into the
door and so for the next six months we
worked super hard and it was a difficult
project and we found a way to solve the
problems
so we sent the paper i sent the paper to
nando de freitas
he's like this is amazing karim he's
like you know what we should co-publish
this and suddenly instadeep is
a starter publishing joint ai research
with deepmind
we publish anonymously the paper to
nurip's the largest conference in the
world
not only we get accepted we get accepted
with spotlight recognition which means
the paper is in the top you know
considered as one of the top of the
conference
and this is
basically coming from just us
at the time with little funding etc but
you see what's common between what you
said in this story is
don't believe it cannot be done if you
have grounds to think that something is
achievable
go ahead and build it
and so you attack everything uh you know
as an early a steel young startup in
2019 we organized ai hack
and the radius
at radis like the stadium huge event i
think some of you might have attended it
was amazing and that's why we're doing
it again this year but
what i'm saying here is
you know people said you're crazy a
thousand people in a stadium whatever
and it cost us a lot of money i said no
no it's the right thing to do we do it
it got us such great feedback amazing
people joined the team and so this kind
of opportunities we're going to bring
them to this
this summer to tunisia and this will be
the largest machine learning and ai
event in the history of the country
and i'm not kidding never in the history
of the country did you have top deep
mind researchers top google ai apple
microsoft
facebook meta all these people are going
to come to tunisia meet young talent and
the spirit is giving back the same way
we
you know benefited from this
extraordinary opportunity four years ago
in 2018 we want to bring it back to the
ecosystem so this brings me to the point
on really i believe there is tremendous
potential for tech startups in tunisia
but it's about doing it's not about you
know having talks et cetera it's about
building so what's uh what's uh what's
what's unique about uh tunisia like what
makes tunisia a great place to start a
company from and what makes it all so
hard and how can you how can we
correct the hardness how can you make it
from tunis to outside tunis
yeah yeah i mean
what's hard i think you all know what's
hard right
i don't need to lecture you on what's
hard in tunisia we all banged our heads
on the wall we all lost a thousand times
building the paperwork so going for
doing legalizing a signature all that
stuff yeah so
where the opportunity is is i generally
believe tunisia can be
a really leading hub in africa and in
the arab world when it comes to tech and
deep tech even deep tech ai and other
technologies so why is because you know
the educational system even though
people are saying it's going down and
stuff it is still top-notch i am amazed
by the talents we have i am amazed by
you know like even someone like you yeah
like young externally talented extremely
sharp this gives me hope for the future
of this country and so the mix of
elite tech talent we have
which right now their mentality is just
i want to get out of the country and
work to europe or work in the us
well in reality the opportunity is much
bigger than that
and so how could you turn the country
into
an amazing hub of talent and tech and
success stories and
vibrant ecosystem many huge success
stories
is
if we focus on
digital yeah this is critical if you
don't focus on digital
you're gonna be run into the ground like
literally like try to import export
stuff good luck yeah this kind of thing
so digital you press a button you're
literally like sending bits and your
product is in new york he's in china
he's in europe
so that's the number one point and the
second point which i think is also
another common
dna between instead deep and and go my
code is the fact that from day one and
you express this very well
you have an international ambition
this is not a tunisian project
it is an international ambitious project
run from tunis which is very different
so from day one even later on the
investors the people you're on board you
want them to be people
who have an international
prospect yeah when you raise money don't
raise money from local institutions
which i believe do not have the right
standards to build the successes of
tomorrow go and raise from the world's
best investors now the good news is
they're all looking for projects like
yours like everybody's looking for
amazing projects like like insta-deep
like go my code etc so if you have
enough quality in your project internet
like in international scope
raising money is actually easy so
believe it or not if you go try to raise
money from local institutions in dnr
it's going to be extremely hard it's
going to get you probably not very far
so
they're smart investors locally go with
the smart ones and those are
international background or go straight
out to international investors yeah yeah
i mean something so there is a i call
them the ace
um
as the advantage of launching a company
from tunis and the bees as like the
barriers to launch a company from tunis
i can outline a lot of barriers one of
them is we have really really
complicated exchange
currency exchange lows as
to launch an international company
you're not going to launch it with dnrs
for us to launch gomez dakar or lagos or
we cannot launch a country with the nars
to crack a country you need usds
but you're the money you're making in
the country is in dinners and it's very
hard to convert dinners so that makes it
really really hard to expand with
dinners and with local investors so what
you need to do is you need to raise a
new sd
and to raise in usd you need to look
outside you need to
look for international investors
with a strong ambition for africa
uh which
we have a lot today and it's extremely
increasing the the the money is not the
problem money so yes money is not the
problem and this is really
something i learned really the the
through the recent fundraise which is
money is not the problem and there is
this interesting multiplier effect that
is happening right now in the market as
we're going to have more successful
startups and we're going to have more
successful ai companies and we're going
to have more successful at tech
companies and that will bring a lot of
positive effect to the to the to the
ecosystem one of the things that i can
really recall which is the institute
fund raise
fueled the gomer coach fundraise the
very very same investors of unsteady
really really believed in the gom code
model
and they invested in comment code
because they seen it working against a
deep so there is this multiple effect
that we never had before that will play
in your advantage so it's really not a
question of uh investor it's really a
question of uh uh executing and
operating uh yeah exactly and just on
that so if you're trying to have a
project trying to raise money you have a
hard time it just means that you're not
talking to the right investors or that
your project is not set up for
international success but because trust
me like the number of people we talk to
that are as you said looking for the
next success story having been
successful in their previous investments
could be instead deep could be others is
insane so if you set up the project the
right way you will find funding and that
that is uh that is something that has
completely changed recently but not to
the second point you mentioned
we know like this is actually our dream
and our secret plan for the futures like
how do we make this country
a deep tech leader how do we make this
country relevant for the future like
south korea is relevant today
well we need success stories
and you know like the fact that the
series b of insta-deep uh so shattered
some so-called sort of glass ceiling in
terms of fundraising in africa which is
i mean i'm pleased to hear that it's
directly benefiting you the same way the
success of go my code will benefit
others
this is the secret plan it's like we
built
from strength to strength from success
to success
and
if we do this with the right sort of
strategy it will create incredible
opportunities to all of you and
incredible opportunities to give back
you know what's interesting about our
companies they're doing a lot to give
back to the ecosystem i mean i just told
you like the two large events we're
doing this summer
go my code is having an incredible
positive beneficial impact on the
ecosystem so
success
shows that success is possible a smart
tunisian or smart young african
uh potentially having equipped himself
with great skills from go my code
you know he could work for a company in
europe have a great salary okay fine
because he could build something much
more disruptive either join a disruptive
team here and enjoy scalable uh
exponential returns or build his own
project and and do it even at a larger
scale so
we want to change the mentality we want
to show it's possible to be successful
from here
and if you're a bit ambitious you want
to go to europe and us but if you are
really ambitious build a big success
because it's possible today there's also
something interesting um that i think a
lot of founders need to think about
smartly which is you have two companies
that went from seed stage to series and
series b
in edtech and in ai so there is a comp
there is an opportunity here so you can
meaning that the market is really
interesting to build for education and
to build for ai right now from tunis and
i think for education specifically
because i can see this there's a million
thing that a lot of founders can build
for education i think the market the
educational market in tunisia is really
mature
so you can really build for a lot uh in
education and i think there is a company
comp a pounding effect which is like
gomez if anything is going to grow and
it's going to go to series b series c
and gomez will start thinking about
supporting other attacks and supporting
other education founders so there is no
same for ai same for unsteady so there
is an opportunity to go behind these
companies and try to build and try to
also solve their opinions and i i saw
this happening a lot in lagos like uh
fletcher waves is buying a lot of
fintechs it's buying a lot of fintechs
that started a few years after federal
wave for example so there is like a comp
compounding effect behind education and
ai in terms which is actually it's a
really good mature an opportunity for
you to build for education ai right now
and it's a and the compounding
factor is basically entrepreneurial
success and entrepreneurs
wanting to give back to the ecosystem so
i know both yahya and i we're totally
into this right and so it's a revolution
in mentality you know we still live in a
world unfortunately where people think
that
uh wealth is limited that wealth comes
from the ground and that you know
fighting for the ground and you know the
oil and stuff is the most important
thing on on earth
but in reality
we want to create a culture of abundance
wealth is unlimited the only limiting
factor is yourself digital wealth is
unlimited doesn't mean it's easy to get
you need to work very hard and all the
advice we're giving you etc but
potentially it is unlimited and it's
available to you so this revolution of
mentality it also means like
competitors like old school tunisia
old-school africa oh my competitor is
someone i'd never want to talk to or my
like that other company etc i never
share my secrets et cetera us we're
radically open i'm telling you
everything is going on about instagram
you tell everything's going on about go
my code and we want to empower you and
we want to build relationship between
new successful tech companies in tunisia
and africa
where
success brings success where the pie
keeps growing it's not about oh this is
small pie how much percent i can get of
that small pie and you know that's the
mentality no the pie is unlimited and
let's grow and
let's build it together and so for me
this is an extraordinary opportunity
i don't think tunisia and for that
matter africa
will ever have this opportunity again
i was a few weeks ago uh invited
incredibly at the panel at the opening
of the africa forum so this is 1500 ceos
like most famous ceos uh or most
successful ceos in africa
incredibly they told me kareem can you
come with heads of state for the opening
panel so i was there with the president
of ghana and stuff like never happened i
was like okay so i said you know what i
will tell them what is really going on
and i told them this and this is why i
want to share it with you
ai and digital deep tech innovation
is the transforming technology of our
time of your life
it's going to be bigger than the
internet economically and socially this
is as big as it gets and if you follow a
little bit what's going on you will see
that this is really happening okay
the difference is
the last time we had a really disruptive
technology that really changed the order
of countries changed the winners
redefined everything in the 20th century
it was nuclear power okay
nuclear power think about it this is as
hidden secretive government controlled
as you can imagine like literally like
building nuclear power capability is not
gonna happen you need like uh
resources like plutonium and others or
uranium that are impossible to source uh
the knowledge is very hidden very
secretive like people are killing
literally killing themselves for that
knowledge you never hear about nuclear
engineers or yeah they're always hiding
them but yeah but it's that the impact
of nuclear energy is crazy both in war
and peace okay well it's the same with
ai but guess what ai is open ai and
digital is completely open
and watch the skills you're learning
with go my code they're exactly the
right digital skills to become
a contributor
into the most disruptive technology and
opportunity of your life and that is
insane there is a crazy opportunity this
means africa and in particular tunisia
can leapfrog
what does it take to get there it gets
we work very very hard and we focus on
building there rather than trying to hey
optimize salary here or get a job here
focus on building there is so much to be
built i totally agree with you like the
number of
successful
projects that could emerge or the
opportunities that you have joining
potentially an already like
successful a sort of like tech first
company like go my code or like instead
go for those don't go for a classic job
because that's part of the past and the
future is happening at insane speech you
know like that's what people don't tell
you so this is so i wanted to convey
that sense of urgency but also sense of
opportunity because i really believe
that
uh founders like
success stories like go my code like in
study are the future of this country
this is not a small matter this is the
most important thing that is going to
happen in the next 20 30 years either we
are part of the story part of the train
or the train will live without us
this is such a good point i mean a lot
of people ask us at my code and be like
what do you really do at gomaycode and
we were we through the years we had
different answers so we'd say like we're
a school we're a platform we train
people we're like a digital skills
platform
but it made me a few years to realize
really what you do and it
it took me also a lot of traveling to
and especially with the expansion that
you did i spent a lot of time
going to dakar to abijah to lagos
casablanca to the countries where we are
we where we operate and something i
really realized really really well which
is
probably in the lifetime history of the
humanity we never had this before which
is we have a lot of youth specifically
in africa it's a 200 million people
between the age of 14 and 200.
between 14 and 30.
sorry it's a 200 million people between
the age of 14 and uh and 30 maybe in the
future we live to 200 who knows yeah you
know like could happen
could happen yes could happen which is a
really really high dance uh these
countries are really high dance with
youth okay so
and you see a lot of like young people
living in their countries interacting
with the country's economy
but
they only get to see what's happening
outside
they only get to see this global digital
economy like you know in tunisia as
tunisians we see what's happening we
know it's happening we we are following
the trends in europe in asia but we
we see the digital global economy but we
live in a really old-school economy
right
and i was like what does it take for our
people to be really really active in
this global economy in this new digital
economy and get beyond the local old
school economy and i think this is what
really gomicode is doing which is if you
learn a tech skill
meaning as you can work outside you can
work uh remotely you can get to work on
tech projects you can get to work on
open source projects you can you can you
get to interact with people from all
over the world from your existing
countries we have a lot of a lot of
students in lagos work for european
companies a lot of students in in ibiza
who work for a tunisian company so tech
actually created this distribution in
global economy which is like we don't
have this concept of local economy you
have like one global economy and
everyone and interacting with which is
the first time in humanity like as a
tunisian you can leave a dent in the
global economy and not not just in your
country economy and this is what really
gomecod is trying to do is like
we really want to make people active and
really contributing in the global
economy in this new digital economies
even from their existing countries and
from their mother countries which is
something really really important um
yeah so yeah and
basically like what you guys doing and
what we're doing is essentially the same
is empowering young talents
with advanced digital skills to be
successful and master the technologies
that will make history in this country
in this in this century this is as
simple as that but the good news of all
this
is
the barrier to entry is extraordinarily
low actually i like to see what you guys
are doing as even lowering the barrier
to entry into the digital world because
go my code like it really gives you
useful skills
at a cost which is super reasonable
and literally giving you the ability to
evolve in this world so with the right
mentality you can go very very far but
remember everything we told you on
on
on themes specific topics on which you
have an unusual differentiated
advantage but this is happening and you
can really be part of it
and
try always to learn from the very best i
like what you said about the fact that
now the world is connected that
tunisians can be part and africans can
be part of the digital economy so go and
learn from the very best so you're
thinking about startups go and do
learn from startup school from y
combinator the best accelerator in the
world don't
localize you yourself in terms of like
ambitions capabilities go and learn for
the very best and then come up with a
product that could be local but
differentiated world class etc but so
really like see yourself you're part of
the global digital infrastructure go my
code is helping you be part of it and
essentially you can
start to become a contributor to this
ecosystem iterate from there later on
raise money etc but you're the first
generation for whom this is possible
even us at the beginning in 2014 when we
started there was no funding available
for
a deep tech ai company like us in
tunisia that was really science fiction
now there is a lot more funding
available the number of teams in the
world really looking and digging and
trying to find the stand the new hot
starter before everybody else is insane
and it's about the quality raise the bar
take for standards
world-class standards
you know he was in silicon valley i
worked in the u.s okay so you could say
we had an advantage and it's true that's
i'm very transparent the fact that i
studied at ecole polytechnic in france i
worked in the us i was admitted at
stanford and where i worked in applied
mathematics in new york you were in
silicon valley you sought for sun this
is an advantage but here is the point
and this is a very important point you
see
we are still a generation where we
needed to go to the us to get the
knowledge and come back to build but now
i believe is not necessary anymore why
because the knowledge
is available on the internet but it
takes more than knowledge it takes the
right nurturing environment and i think
it's a shared ambition
that
in steady go my code are strong
contributors to this positive
environment where you're going to find
mentors for your project you're going to
find help later you might even find
funding right like you said investor
like entrepreneurs giving back companies
giving back so we sort of
removing the needs
to have to travel
to build digitally disruptive businesses
and so my dream is
one of the next big successes we're
going to hear from tunisia in digital
and tech is actually from an
entrepreneur
who grew up
did all his career in tunisia and he's
an international player being this is a
product he's a global product he has
global investors but he didn't need to
go anywhere to do this and i believe
this is possible especially with a
nurturing environment which we're trying
to push
which is essentially recreating the
conditions of silicon valley here
including the fear of missing out the
funding the advice etc and i think that
should be our common ambition and i
think it's possible actually and uh
we're gonna try to do it you know yeah
great um
i think we can start taking questions uh
so feel free to like uh throw questions
and like start asking yeah yeah okay
um yeah the audience was particularly uh
excited
i mean if
if if we don't like stop like it's gonna
take us yeah we could go on all day you
know you have to stop us
me too
let me first introduce myself uh i'm
mesh tufi i'm the founder of startup
that is building a solution for the
retail industry for lagos distribution
um i wanted to know what makes
an investor
better than the other because i'm
talking about with a lot of investors
and let's say 90 percent of them is
are willing to give money and
uh
i don't need the only money i need the
guy sometimes not bad by the way yeah
that's what i was going to say like you
actually want an investor
that is giving you
money and not trying to interrupt you
too much
just is available when you need him you
need him for introduction for example
guy reaching out a certain person a
certain company and you know he has the
contact he's available and he will help
but otherwise he's stepping out of your
way it's funny because investors they
will always come to tell you oh i'm
gonna help you run your business better
or gonna have an expertise into scaling
forget about that you don't want any
advice or expertise the only advice you
want is when you are going to ask for
advice
yeah if you say i need help you raise
your hand then you want that person to
help but beyond that
if they could just
let you run the show and demonstrate
that you are delivering results and sage
well done that's what the best investor
okay i have another tricky question one
question you should ask when you talk to
investors which is like
what have they done
or what companies they have invested in
simply so for me the best investors
are our founders
as investors who
pre-investing were building companies
for me the best investor is katie
because he built the company he grew a
company from c to series b and now he's
ambassador so he really understands
for me that's the best type of investor
is people who actually
done
startups built startups and after
uh started investing so that's for the
best uh investors type and they called
operators investors as they operated
before the second type of good investor
is they usually they have a good
portfolio as the investors of strife
and airbnb and they have relatively like
good traction you know so that also
helps to have investors with extraction
as invested in companies that grew and
been sold and like you know african best
they have a strong struct attraction in
africa uh as they invested in and
studied before so it makes sense for us
to have them and as an investor because
they invested foreign so look also for
attraction and like you know what kind
of companies they invested in before so
these are my advice
never invest with a player who is
focused on just a single market is sort
of narrow-minded on a single market that
is not the investor you want and he will
try to drive you off track
startups
actually
have issues growing to their full
potential simply because of the wrong
investor base and the pressure they're
getting
the program also with international
investors they don't look necessarily at
you if you're just in tunisia so it
actually helps to be in different
countries so you can bring international
investors it helps her i'm not saying it
couldn't happen but it helps
to be in multiple countries so you bring
that kind of international investors
my investors are also my clients
that's good sometimes it depends on the
nature of your product yeah i'm doing
b2b and the market is narrow like in
terms of agents like we have this is a
very good one i will b2b business also
we have investors uh who are our clients
we have biotech we have dutch shabbat
the reason it works with us is because
we're building great relationships and
long-term relationships with them and so
an investment makes the relationship
even longer you have to be careful
that
if you're a b2b business
it doesn't sort of cannibalize the other
opportunities you have
for us
meaning like imagine
your market is like you know 20 big
players one of them wants to become
really close to you and invest in you
problem is others might be then afraid
to do something with you because you are
seen as you're part of their competition
the reason why it works for instanti
is because ncd is a global ai company
and so we have multiple verticals so we
have b2b relationships but they are not
in the same sector so those do not see
themselves as competitor to each other
so for us it works
maybe for others it doesn't so be
careful if it is a single vertical
it's probably not a good idea to take
the money if you have multiple verticals
and this is not going to be seen as oh
you took aside
then maybe you can have that so you have
to look at the drawbacks actually
indonesia i have in terms of numbers
[Laughter]
ask them to be part of my company
instead of having one and making the
others afraid of me that's probably a
better idea you don't want to lose
clients yeah you want the act of
investing
to be an opportunity to develop your
business so yeah yeah thank you the only
thing that you
should care about is it's like a local
player
it's a local player so
i don't know it maybe it makes more
sense to have um
a more up an african uh
look for example careful i know
are like in many african countries you
know francophonica yeah so it makes
sense maybe to talk with cafe france you
know because they own or they own a lot
of cafes all over across the
so you know you can ask them to
introduce you to car for france and
invest through kafo france maybe or like
you know so it actually helps to have
much an international player in the long
run
we can take from here
okay
that's a funny mic too stephanie mike
good morning everyone thank you for your
insights i would say my name is
absolutely not in uh okay directly in
tech i'm a lawyer
um we need lawyers we need good lawyers
i work as a real consultant and it's a
tech it's a problem now yeah yes and
that's
my question actually uh i work with uh
actually it's a law firm in brussels
american author
uh and i specialize in competition law
anti-trust compliance okay so my
question is uh how
starting from tunis do you manage to
deal with all the legal barriers because
i know they exist
and my second question is more oriented
to kareem actually how do you
do your business
uh with
very
specific um
legal constraints when it comes to you
talked about um biotech and actually i
represent
a competitor of theirs um
how do you
design your product uh considering all
the
legal constraints
that apply to pharma or uh when it comes
to deutsche ban to transport especially
in europe uh where uh there is today a
project of an ai act and it will be the
first ai act in the world
um
that
which will definitely apply to your
business
uh i mean the first question is like a
really hard question
i think a lot of founders depending on
the business that you're running
um
our kind of business is like really
complicated legally to be honest with
you because we operate as um as
independent companies in every country
so in every country with opening company
and um
i would say it's a staged thing you
shouldn't necessarily think about these
kind of things as you're starting
um as like if you start from tunis start
with the company in tunisia and you
figure out like solution later on
what's really important is to have a
good uh lawyer
that's this is my really my genuine
because a good lawyer will eventually
find a way to tell you how to
um because the problem is not to me is
the problem is like once you think about
expansion international expansion like
what do you do do we do you start
creating subsidiaries from tunisia or do
you reallocate
in a strategic country that you can
create subsidiaries from
um it's very complicated to create
seven for example subsidiaries from
tunisia in our case so we had to
relocate in in different countries
and from that country create
subsidiaries
and uh there are good countries that a
lot of investors trust and they have
good laws where you can create
subsidiaries but for our case it was
only after three years or four years
actually of existing then we started
thinking about this let's put it this
way like in the beginning don't worry
about the stuff keep it simple and focus
on the product and iterating and at that
moment you're mostly like a one-country
team
later on like i said hire experts to do
this kind of stuff yeah but like you
should not start the project yeah this
is important you should not start the
project trying to optimize the stuff
like do how take best advice and just do
it but don't waste time on
the details of this kind you know how
you sometimes when you write code it
doesn't need necessarily to be perfect
like it's a hard coded code like it's a
it takes some time to like test and
clean and like document the code and
like and it's fine at first to like
start with whatever it if it works okay
uh this is like exactly like you know
like
a good plan executed uh today is better
than a perfect plan executed next week
just get going yeah and don't worry
later on people will come and tell you
okay will you reincorporate we do this
okay fine take the right advice then the
good thing is there are a lot of
solutions there is a million solution
it's going to
be probably tough but this is something
i'm precisely planning to do which is
i'm going to create like an article on
how to make it from tunis legally
because it's a
legally because it's a big challenge and
i personally struggled with a lot you
know it took us you know five years to
get to the stage where i know for a fact
if we had the right knowledge maybe at
first
it maybe it will take us like three
years to to do this stage this is now
the the the field is playing like yeah
there will be standards and best
standards and you should definitely do
this because this is a point which is uh
yeah yeah yeah
so on my side yeah on
ai and it's a question about ip
essentially intellectual property we
have ip agreements with our customers
in general instead eep is as an ai
player has its own technological stack
and ip which is about the ai but with
the application sometimes we do actually
give ip to our partners in a specific
use case and this is usually what
they're interested in so there are ways
to do this
and you talked about ai regulation yes
it's good that ai gets regulated
because ai is the nuclear power of this
uh century and so this means that with a
powerful technology like this bad users
will start emerge and will become
actually incredible so you need a bit of
regulation but it wouldn't affect us
because
instead by design
does not do
bad stuff or controversial stuff
we do things which are unequivocally
good for society saving lives trying to
detect dangerous variants before they
start growing
improving the efficiency of large
railway networks these are not
controversial so we steer away from this
but definitely regulation is needed
because the technology is insanely
powerful i think you saw recently uh
an engineer actually going out and
talking about like the the fact that hey
these systems are they look like they
are conscious
yeah
for me you know it's definitely not
conscious or not yet but it tells you
that we're sort of passing the turing
tests you know the altering test that
hey now you are a point where you cannot
recognize
if this is a person or an ai
and this means that if you cannot
recognize
this is really dangerous and could be
badly used so we definitely need some
sort of regulation
the key thing is this a smart regulation
would be perfect
it's going to take a lot of time
probably 50 years to get to a stage
maybe less i don't know maybe it's going
to take longer
and it's going to take like there's
like an effect to get those regulations
up like used in africa also like you
know there's a but yes
yeah you never know right there
cool question there yeah yes
it's
insurance but to
try to make things easy and more
digestible
and
my question
[Music]
to be recorded
so uh actually
i don't know if you know uh so much
about finances and the insurance market
but it is a heavy regulated industry our
boyfriend here knows better than us that
you can't
enter to play in the insurance market
globally unless you have the right
agreements and capital and so on so on
uh
let alone in tunisia
so
we are trying
my question is about how to move from an
initiative to a business because
actually we are trying uh to launch we
are actually in the final stage of
launching an initiative that helps
people understand
insurance products and how to benefit
from insurance
here in tunisia in the tunisian dialect
actually we took the legal
uh contracts and we try to make it as
simple as possible so and to build
something around it around it to make
people
at least they have a source to turn to
when they are confronted with
maybe the question is like how do you
thrive in very regulated markets
insurance is one of the things it could
be also fintech in tunisia feedback is
really highly regulated right
it could be insurance it could be and
how to move from an initiative not we
are not going to charge people to get
information but we are thinking about
investing efforts and
ideas in this in the risk industry
advice in general as a young startup
try to avoid heavily regulated
situations so i know your insurance is
heavily regulated
find a way that the product you do is
not regulated it's just an advice or
find a way that it's not regulated
because the reality of regulation this
is true worldwide is particularly true
in tunisia and in africa
is that it will get you it will slow you
down something incredible incredible and
so
if you can avoid you should avoid
because startups live and die by
momentum startups live and die by what
did you do next week what are you doing
next month and if the answer is i'm
waiting for the okay of the regulator
and these people there they live in
another planet compared to startups yeah
for them you wait uh four months is
normal yeah
you four months you could be dead by
then so try to avoid as much as possible
and if really your business model is i
must get an okay from regulators you
should ask yourself
in which country you do this and you
should it should be a very large country
where the regulator is
kind of like relatively fast it should
not be a small country with a very heavy
or slow regulatory regime that's my
advice because you will be dependent on
people really for the life of death your
business which do not care and will not
care about it
i'll tell you two things one thing it
really helped a lot that
professional training is not for my god
is not like highly regulated
um as it is in africa so it actually
helped that we are not in a very
regulated industry which is like
professional training
nothing no
almost barely no regulation and that
helped really really speed up the
process of expansion trying things
rolling out products faster so it helps
massively to be in a non-regulated
market my second thing is you should
talk to anis
our friend there of lucy of cowan which
is a rising fintech in tunisia which is
i think he would advise you uh
he would probably advise you better than
anyone on uh being in a highly regulated
uh and building a fintech uh actually
maybe he wants a question
so we've made all the mistakes possible
when it comes to dealing with regulators
having the product structure being
closely tied to
constraints that we cannot control
so definitely even in terms of our own
expansion we're looking at restructuring
the product itself to be less reliant on
those factors uh when it comes to
getting started i think what you're
doing uh could could definitely work
it's just about getting one partner or
one paying client which is for example a
big insurance company that wants to dive
into this with you
so so you don't have to necessarily to
go through say getting your own license
or getting your own
complicated structure going you can work
with the constraints of that market and
launch something that isn't necessarily
waiting for new regulation to come in i
think that that's key for example when
we started um and
i'll preface this by saying we took
three years to get the the
authorizations to launch but um it would
have taken a lot more had we waited for
a change of regulation instead of
interpretation of the current law so we
actually took the text of law we read it
even though we're tech people at heart
we just switched into
a different mode of um
looking at current law reading it and
interpreting it with the with with the
eye of a tech person who can use
technology to work within the
constraints of the law it's not
particularly fun but i think
if you choose to work within regulated
sectors
that is once you move in on to the other
side is a huge barrier to entry for
competitors so it gives you
some leeway once once you actually
launch your product or figured out these
constraints that becomes the muscle and
expertise that allows you to maybe go
faster than anyone else who's trying to
copy what you do
this is and we can talk later the
interesting thing about regulation which
is
they they don't necessarily change out
of nature so
they usually historically when you look
they usually change out of pressure or
out of social behaviors change
so if you come up with something that
will put some pressure on the the social
economy or like the government or like
the government will eventually need to
to do some change you know so it's
easier to to come up from the other side
so if if lucy is doing a lot of work
like around fintech and it's getting a
lot of traction and it's growing and if
lucy found like
a hack or a way to get in
and it grew that's gonna put a lot of
pressure on regulators to start rig
to start changing regulations and it's
usually that you know it's it's only
after six years of uber existence that
they started or like trying to regulate
uh
like you know or it's only best advice
and this is true for everybody here
if you're starting a company as a
startup in africa
in indonesia
try to minimize your regulatory
footprint try to minimize
the your government intervention
footprint i'll give you a concrete
example i learned this the hard way so
what i'm telling you here cost me a lot
of money because before instead i failed
the project
because it was just requiring lots of
interaction with customs and stuff and
it killed the project okay so really
like try to minimize to the max
mistakes you should not do for example
we if you look at the the text in low uh
you know i come from tattooing right so
there are lots of like oh it's a social
development area like lots of help like
you're supposed to like like the
football uh sports laser i was a project
was supposed to help like get a lot of
state help and whatever
the reality is
even if you're supposed to get a lot of
government help
you should bypass that and not take that
government help and not ask for it you
know why because even if it happens that
you get the help it will take years and
it will slow you down it will put you in
a tough so learn to rely on yourself
that is the biggest lesson minimize the
footprint to the minimum ideally zero
and
don't expect help let others get the
help you are young you're talented
you're fast moving you can get funding
you don't need to make a business plan
based on when you will get state help or
other large government or development
bank help etc it doesn't work for
startups trust me this cost me a lot
to have give you this advice and this
will save you a lot of time
it's a really really good advice yeah
this year
founder of management of management
consulting companies very different from
from yours i was in tech but now in
management i have a question here i have
a challenge about people retention
because to have an amazing success you
need amazing people
and
and likes i feel like most people are
here to to learn new things for for two
three four years and looking for a job
in france in silicon valley and four
years is not bad
that's what i was thinking
i thought you're gonna say like six
months for like one year that's like
okay okay so so what are your secrets
for people retention
yeah so the first uh first secret is
you need to lead from the front
yeah it's like if the founders
the the worst retention situation for
tunisian business
the owners are in europe or in the us or
somewhere in the world
they are not here like the founders or
the owners whatever this is run here on
the concept of oh this we have this
office because it's cheaper this will
fail and retention will will be very low
okay people will leave the right way to
do it is the founders should be here at
least some of the founders like zohara
and my co-founder is running the tunis
office so she is here with the team i
come regularly markovi they couldn't
come too much but now i'm all the time
coming to tunis so
that's the engagement and the second
part make thing exciting you know people
they don't work just for the money you
know even though we talk a lot about
they leave because they're better
salaries in europe yes actually people
love a challenge if you show them this
is an exciting mission if you show them
there is progress potential off the
scale
they will stay with you even if you
don't have the best salary offer that's
another point and the third part is you
should be very generous with stock
options because we're talking about
building exponential wealth here yeah
bill gates did not become rich or elon
musk did not become rich taking a salary
they became rich because they had a
share in a very successful exponentially
growing business so it's important that
all your employees receive stock options
you know this is our culture at instead
you know even our you know when we
started our our house cleaner omel here
at instagram she got shares of instagram
and we have a plan so that all the time
we give shares to all the employees
based on merits but it's this
participation thing if you run a
two-tier office
if you don't care about people you don't
have an exciting mission and you don't
get them to be a shareholder of your
business and your success
well obviously it's gonna fail if you do
all this
maybe they will stay and they will
become great uh partners with time and
great future leaders of the company
yeah retention is really really a
challenging uh thing to to manage and um
i'd say you know for example gomez is a
really really big it's a big people
company like it's a
it's not it's a 500 teachers it's uh we
have a 5 000 students and you'd say for
every 10 students you have a teacher
so that's almost 500 teachers studying
teaching
so it's a big big people company so how
do you retain the teachers and
especially what you learned that people
in tech
they usually want to code i mean they
usually want to write code and let's
teach early on in their careers so
you'll have more people in tech wants to
build product and wants to code and less
people who wants to teach
so you actually need to convince this
experience that tech people and these
like really good tech people to teach
which is a really really hard thing and
you should and you need to convince them
to do this during the weekends and on a
saturday afternoon on a sunday afternoon
and like full time during the week
so and i'd say three things for for me
that i saw really really important one
it actually helps it helps to
keep people if you hire for culture and
not just uh so it's really important to
hire for culture as
if you have people living it's not
necessarily a company
it's it could be a culture as like the
person is not necessarily fit for the
culture so it actually helps to be set
and be like okay what kind of things i
really what kind of behaviors and skills
that i really appreciate in the people
that i hire for example for us we really
want to want to hire builders like we
really want to hire people who build
stuff before you know it helps to have
builders on the team so
it's really important to hire an
interview for for culture and ask people
like what do you what for example like
we ask this for a lot of people is like
what do you appreciate in your
colleagues and what do you really value
on your manager as like a value or like
as a skill and it helps to hire for
culture to optimize um longer so yeah
culture this also means that you have to
be passionate remember what you're
talking about beginning if you are
passionate passion is contagious they
will get passionate about what you do
and so you have to keep things fun
exciting
and
it's a underappreciated thing but i
actually believe that companies that
give back
a lot to the ecosystem
actually retain people way more meaning
that if you have a good karma kind of
culture that this is not a company which
goal is to just make money and that's it
and we all go to the beach here it's
like there's a culture
really agents positive agents of change
we're helping we're doing
lots of initiatives which can be
actually very costly or very time
consuming and working on weekend stuff
have that vibe
that this is a movement that this is
beyond a business you know and if you
look at you know what you guys are doing
and what we are doing there is a little
bit of that it's it's a bit of a
movement like change things improve the
ecosystem give back to society
this is ultimately
what can be can create a great company
so there is a huge mission behind which
is a mission that is beneficial to all i
give you example tesla
is a mission-driven company they want to
revolutionize transportation and reduce
the impact and develop like sustainable
mobility spacex is
a mission-driven company like uh
populate mars and beyond okay
guess what they have the best talent of
the us in engineering going to these
best talent is not going for other
companies so you have to build something
exciting and demonstrate that you are
helpful to society because in my
experience the very best people the best
talents
they don't come just for the money of
course they want to come and be a big
success that people are going to talk
about et cetera
you have to have that but if you have
that component of
i'm really doing something important
positive
good karma and i'm not doing it for any
sort of return or whatever this is
genuine well it's going to create a much
more interesting company and people will
stay yeah
yeah you may ask like what's a a quick
tip on like how do you find
a mission or like a vision
really simply it could be like a formula
the word is x today
x
with my vision the work is y
and if you come up with your x and y and
it's bold
that's uh could be a proper vision like
just the way the better and the bolder
the better like the word is not
connected today with facebook the word
is connected and one place so you can
simplify it that way like it's a because
i get asked all the time about this so
it's like really
building the digital ai potential of
africa instead of building the ai
capabilities and bridging the developing
world with the developed world with a
better future for ai you see benefits
everyone it has to be bold otherwise the
top talents they don't want to come just
because they think they're going to make
money with you they will make money with
anyone they could work with any for
anyone they want something special which
is exciting and that fits what they want
to do in life you know the bar is high
but if you
structure it like this way trust me
people will come and you will never have
a problem hiring top talents and keeping
them
i mean
uh go ahead yeah you
you will still
you know all of this and you still fight
to manage retention and you will still
to you'll still have people living and
honestly the best way is also to manage
retention is like to accept retention
because we live in a in a generation
where like where
uh people actually leave companies
really fast like it's not the same as
our like father's generation or like
people are like more comfortable in
staying in companies two or three years
going to the second company so it helps
to accept it mentally also
no the the the relocation thing i i
think study we have we basically have a
policy now
that if you are an employee in tunis
uh if you're doing a great job after a
certain number of years you will be
offered opportunities abroad so it has
to be you have to take into account what
the team wants but it goes the other way
we also have talents in europe that want
to come to discover you know our african
offices
you know again this is not an easy
thing and
is right
but it can be managed if you're a super
exciting company and
you know the last secret of retention is
momentum
a company that has extraordinary
momentum
will not lose its top talent because
people sense when this is really
exciting when there's something
happening and they want to be part of it
you know so if you're not sure
make it make it bold make it exciting
make it fun and move
ultra fast
you know as we said good plan today
better than perfect plan you know
tomorrow or next week
kerim uh i really want you to know that
uh
it's a big honor for me
to meet you physically uh and this
passion for answered even for you've
been like
like since you had the speech at mit and
since i heard about the bion tech
funding and stuff and this is really
shocked me either when i when i knew
that this is a tunisian like maybe half
tunisian it's a tunisian like work you
know i'm saying
and so i have two questions for you and
two questions for yahi
there's a point that i always
that always made me uh
always made me how can i say uh confused
and it's which do i really need a
engineering degree to be an ai engineer
like do i really need
engineering
in ai and data science and this circle
to have what can the ai engineer
does
is it necessarily or it only depends on
the coding skills and
the innovation in this field
the question is
do i need to
to expand to reach out all the fields
like uh ai solutions in sports ai
solutions
in art ai solutions and education ai
solutions in healthcare
ai solutions in wars no i'm joking so
is it uh or do i need to focus on one
end on one industry
so thank you maybe i'll answer this too
and then you can ask yeah yeah yeah
these two questions is there two like uh
you know yes
so the first the first question about
like what do you need
technically speaking if you are
showing exceptional talent in ai
and you could see it through for example
like your you know code on github that
you you built things that that are
really remarkable
we we don't care
where you come from you could have zero
diploma if you showed proof of
exceptional ability we would hire you
obviously we're a deep tech
sort of like a dream team of ai so the
bar to entry is very high but in
principle it's about a ability so it
happens some from time to time that
somebody comes with not the right
background but the right abilities we
take them but most of the time these are
more like
advanced type of profiles ultimately
it's about what you can do it's not
about the diploma so that's how we hire
yes but i'm not talking in terms of
getting a job or something
in just launching an ai startup or
making an impact yeah but first like in
terms of like uh can do can you have an
impact etc
ai is not an easy field
it's not an easy so
if you're just thinking about like
launching a general ai company in 2022
i think it would probably fail and i
don't want to this
sort of like
make you less motivated i will tell you
what would probably succeed and this
answer your second question what would
succeed is
exceptional competence in a given field
we talked about legal here we talked
about insurance and combining that with
ai
ai in general you see like insta-deep is
an ai in general company but we started
in 2014 and now we have
a lot of momentum lot of capabilities
that barrier to entry is very high today
but if you take
a particular vertical where you have
exceptional domain expertise and you
build your domain expertise in ai yes
then you're setting yourself up for
success that's my point of view general
ai today the bar is extremely high
and
what was possible like five six or eight
years ago
is less possible today because there is
a lot of progress competition
so these are my two advice but it is
possible you train yourself you build
your capabilities and you specialize on
something on which you have unique
competence
yes it's possible let me give you an
idea of what could work what could work
would be to address a particular problem
uh using for example conversational ai
a particular problem that you master
very well it could be legal it could be
insurance
in a market where you don't have that so
the large markets the u.s europe they
already have that
tunisia or other
large countries in africa maybe they do
not have those conversational tools
there's a revolution going on in
conversational ai today
this would potentially work if you know
that specific field very well and if
your ai is elite by the way we can help
you
uh this is true for everyone we have a
an initiative where insta dip is
offering free compute
uh of uh our largest uh super computers
like dgx a100s these are like very
powerful machines they cost like half a
million dinners each
and we if you have a project and you
need machine learning we just ask you
that you already have a code that works
and you know what you're doing but we
would give you the compute for free so
uh this is a way also to support the
ecosystem so if you do it this way
i think yes you might be on to something
clear okay
okay
i think you will take two questions per
person to ask to take the maximum from
everyone
and then we will take one question
online and then yes
we take other like let's say four maybe
five questions and yeah we called
first of all i would like to thank you
for your presence here and sharing with
us uh such a precious moment
uh so i am naisak hani i am a computer
science engineer i have 13 years of
experience now i'm project manager since
eight years
in a software it project okay so in fact
i have two questions
first of all if you
have the chance to redo your experience
or redo history what are the decisions
that you may change
i can start yeah that project i had done
before trying to do something regulation
i would never do again yeah that's for
sure so please go digital and go small
footprint or zero footprint with
government and regulation very important
that's number one
number two
on the
insta deep story
to be honest
i wouldn't change many things because
it was a hard path
but somehow it was fulfilling at every
stage we were having fun in the
bootstrap team of insta-deep of the
early days it was fun you know
and what we do now is also very fun very
impactful
so on the insta-deep side
yes perhaps i could have accelerated a
few decisions perhaps we could have
accelerated one of our first ai product
maybe perhaps we could have raised money
faster
but really
i do not think
there could be a potentially
significantly larger scenario than what
we are doing today
and that projects succeeded because
we put all our heart in it and we worked
very hard on something we were
passionate about
and
yeah probably raising money a bit faster
or things like that but nothing really
different the first project change
everything never do anything non-digital
or regulation-heavy
process you have to
the only way to survive is you enjoy the
process i mean ask
for example
like
it's years of hard work or yeah it's
years of hard work if you're doing this
for the money you're going to get bored
very quickly and you're going to realize
like let me put it this way you know we
all talk about like you know the large
fundraiser of instead the amazing
fundraiser of go my code but what people
don't talk about is years and years of
pain of doubt of challenges there is no
get rich or get successful quick scheme
it does not exist and entrepreneurship
is actually being successful the hard
way
the easy way or the relatively easier
way
join a team
that is already on a rocket ship
trajectory then you can be very
successful very quickly at relatively
low risk like join go mic or join study
that's from a risk reward probably the
optimal risk reward never join a normal
business because it's not exponential
but if you want to be entrepreneur
that's the hard way
really that is the hard way like you
better much better be part of an early
stage company that is showing some
traction not super early stage like
showing some traction like today
gomicote has amazing traction and it is
at series a and i'm personally convinced
people like him they are the future of
tunisia like they will be widely
successful if they keep up with the same
passion spirit etc but entrepreneur
don't do it if you think hey
it's happening and people are like doing
all these crazy things
that is in part an illusion because it's
it's the survivorship bias yeah it's
like hollywood yeah you know we all
watch the movies and stuff hollywood
it's like oh you know in back in the
days in the u.s like people say oh i'm
gonna go to hollywood and become a star
like brad pitt well it's a bad choice
because brad pitt is the exception the
guy who was successful and there are a
thousand people applied and they were
good looking and they looked cool and
then and they failed so
don't look at the success uh to make a
decision on an entrepreneur or not so
coming back it has to come from inside
it has to be passion if it is passion
it can be sustained yeah at different
points in the life of the projects
probably true for you
i actually didn't care if we would be
fail or not like meaning that i did
everything i could that were successful
but even failure for me like given what
we are doing in the interest i
considered it a personal success like i
did stuff which i really cared about you
have that mindset and you're fighting
super hard for survive you have a chance
but it will take years
i totally agree with karim you know go
my good i started like as a summer
project it was a summer project it was a
hobby it was a summer a hobby a summer
project and i was planning to go back
next year to university
and after the summer project i was like
it's going to be a gap year it's not
going to be even like a company a guy
peer project
and ended up working on a company you
know so
yeah
thank you so the second question uh
almost you already answered but it's
about difficulties and
how was the risk is if you can describe
for us the risks and high level risks
with important impacts
and how we how was the mitigation that
you use it
okay so
a big risk for me like b2b business and
that's question of b2b
the biggest risk you do as a b2b
business is that you have to invest
a lot of effort and time to convince a
client to become to convert and become
actually paying you revenues
i have a few examples
one big client which we didn't get by
the way we took literally and some of
the people in this room know what i'm
talking about
we worked hard
for 18 months we built
an amazing proof-of-concept product
and we did all this effort
for nothing
it didn't work in the end some people
left that big company which were going
to do it with us and so it didn't happen
however it was a learning process and
the tools we used to use in other
situations etcetera so as a b2b the
biggest risk you have is you invest
massively into
one customer or one relationship to get
you to fruition it could it could be
more than a year sometimes
and it could fail and some cases it
failed and we were like this is insane
we did everything right we have a
product that works
and just the people left things change
and that big company decided not to go
ahead the mitigation is
you diversify if you do this over
multiple high quality partners
some of them will actually work with you
and if they work with you then it grows
et cetera and this is what happened with
the partners you know so that's my
personal feedback on b2b b2b you have to
be really really patient yeah
i have there is like a trailing risk
that i can think of building a company
but maybe to correlate it with gomeiko
specifically
one of the biggest risk that being there
at every single step is in the gomai
code model
you have a lot of atoms versus
like bits you know versus physical
presence you have a lot of atoms like
you have literally physical spaces and
you have more human to train more humans
you need more humans
so
the it makes it really really risky to
grow and to manage you know like i said
to train 10 students you need one
teacher to train more students you need
more square meters as like you need more
chairs
so that can make it really really risky
to grow
to manage the cash flow with
the scale it's very complicated to scale
and it's very very also complicated to
manage the experience of the students
um because it's it's not a hundred
percent like you know uh tech oriented
it's like led by humans and with humans
there is higher probability of risk you
know we have five thousand students
anything could happen at like you know
it's it's really not easy to manage five
thousand students between 20 spaces um
so that's a big big risk in in the go my
code model that you actually use
technology and we use specifically graph
technology to manage to mitigate this
risk a bit which is a technology usually
used in like uh banks and like with
fraud detection you'd like detect fraud
in the graph at the layer of the graph
but you use it at the layer of the skill
so you can know how like the students or
teachers progressing at the layer of the
node and the skill and the
so we had to come up with a lot of
solutions
i mean kapia is his way but you need to
also build a lot of tag to manage the
the the to optimize your chances to have
less risk you know but that's a big
major thing about my code which is like
you actually need to grow you need more
atoms in the model that you're trying to
also uh problem solve as we grow you
know
that's like the biggest risk i think we
we find we have in our model and it's
been there at every single step with
investors with the students with the
teachers you know
um but we're trying to solve you know
but we also try to um to to optimize
what's really good about having spaces
and what's really good about having
teachers in the model and you know um
online yeah
nice we actually have two questions
online uh the first one is for you both
uh when do you know you are ready to
go for international expansion
i mean i think you you you don't
necessarily know
don't
because you know it's it's a it's two
things it's a decision making
that you need it's a decision-making
framework that you like you need to be
utterly convinced that you can and take
the decision to grow you know it's a
really like decision that you need to
take the second thing it's really
it's the product uh
uh you know gomez we spend the first
three years building just building the
product in tunisia like before opening
any other countries we have to open
different locations within the same
countries
so we opened tunis but after we expanded
to source and svetas and you spent two
years
trying to manage suspects because the
complexity went from 10 to 100
you know and specifically in education
it's very very easy to do education for
like small cohorts of students it's very
easy to run a court with 20 students and
you have a lot of schools doing this but
once you go from 20 to 100 to beyond the
complexity gets not two times or three
times gets a hundred times uh so we it
helps to spend a lot of time building
structuring the product it's only when
we had something solid working in
tunisia and we started seeing like good
nps and good completion rates and good
you know metrics and all then we started
okay we have this product we have this
technology we had this user retention we
had this nps okay it makes sense to
expand in other countries so it helps to
have like some maturity into the product
in our case for example
um
yeah
this is the key thing i would say uh it
helps to have some sense of playbook uh
like for example for us like
how do we how do we acquire students do
we have a model for acquiring students
like or like how do we hire teachers do
we have a model for hiring teachers so
it actually
helps to have some sense of models
that you try develop it and you have
accuracy on those models for example us
we only opened new country once we had
the product running once we had the
model kind of figure out like how do we
hire teacher we had also the model of
like how do we acquire students and the
expansion work was mostly replication
it was not innovation it was operation
the expansion was purely operational
work and nothing to do with the product
or nothing to do with the innovation
aspect so i'd say expansion specifically
in b2c businesses are about operational
capacity and less about product
innovation
so i would say like my best advice is
like spend the first two years or like
year depending on the business doing
product innovation product innovation
product innovation once you have good
product with good metrics okay
operational excellence okay replicate
this in multiple locations and spaces so
i don't know yeah i know i totally agree
with it
key thing also is keep in mind that
you need to design your project that it
has a international potential from day
one
and yes you're gonna iterate in one
country
essentially get to product market fit
where you see this is working you're
getting revenues people are re-engaging
with you and and then you're perhaps
ready to go international when you feel
actually clients would benefit from this
or you can reach out more clients but
you as yahya said you need to have
something already going well
so spend the time to iterate locally is
good
but don't get
don't design your project in a way that
it is stuck locally this is very
critical project needs to have
international ambition you talked about
mission from day one then you iterate
locally until it works and then you
prudently open a first office if it
works again that you can be a lot more
aggressive that's when we went to london
first and then very quickly we went all
over africa cape town lagos nigeria et
cetera so when you feel this is working
then you can go all in you know
basically something really exciting
about what you do also and specifically
about tunisia
you think that
a country like senegal would be very
different from tunisia it's not we have
the same problems same issues same
challenges it's exactly the same the
multiple the multiple is different like
maybe
algeria is like three times four times
bigger but same challenges so your
tunisian model can easier can easily
work in algeria you know specifically
for our case and it couldn't work
necessarily in europe for example
but since
in these countries where we operate we
have high unemployment rates we have
like a physical infrastructure we have a
highly educated employee like we have
the same you know patterns in this
country so what worked what worked in
tunisia would potentially work out say
in
countries around like algeria morocco
cote d'ivoire senegal you know
so as someone outsider of the tech field
with an english diploma
where can i start to switch career to ai
and how long would it take me to acquire
the needed skills
[Music]
go to go my code
like seriously like
i'm really excited about what you guys
are building to be honest because
a big challenge is not whether africans
and tunisians will have jobs
you will have jobs why because a big
part of the developed world
is not renewing its population
and it's growing older so you're going
to need people to do the the jobs the
robots are not going to do anything you
know so the question is more
are these jobs going to be
high quality skilled jobs or low quality
low paid low skilled
and the answer is
part of the answer is
actually developing your tech skills and
i think the go my code model is
extremely powerful and relevant there
and so that's the step one of your
evolution to become an ai engineer is
learn the basics at go my code once you
have the basics you know how github
works etc start to learn directly from
the internet etc but my personal belief
is you cannot learn from the internet
alone
it's very difficult because there's just
too much and it's the problem of where
do you find the right relevant
information it's like how to filter and
this is why actually the model of go my
code with one teacher for 10 students is
so powerful because these are people
helping you
know what is relevant and once you start
knowing what works and what doesn't you
continue to learn from good sources and
ultimately you can make your way into
becoming an elite ai engineer but yes
that's go my code is a key step
hi i'm fat matt manny i'm a reporter i
have two questions one for yahya and one
for karim first i want to thank you for
your positive message
i
think that
the most important message is believe in
yourself and think big
so my question for yahya is in tunisia
we have
a culture of fear fear of failure
so when you're a young person how can
you believe in yourself and not listen
to the noise and my question for
and stageep is founded in tunisia buzz
but is a london-based company so was it
easier
was it easier legally
to base the company in london
yeah i mean the fear question is like um
i mean there is a lot of answers for
this right it's not easy you're always
gonna have fear in any way right but
maybe the best answer for this is you
need to get some sort of uh
user validation as like
once you have some users who actually
believe in your product or in your
service that's really good validation
for you to double down and work more on
this and reduce that fear
spend that you have and the more
validation you get from users and the
more trust you get from your clients you
probably build better capacity to manage
the fear to fail and you know
but i think it's really important in our
countries to have a winning mindset also
which is something we
we always think too much about like
failing but it actually helps to have a
winner mindset and like always have a
really good positive uh
you know like what i learned
is that
even if things really go crazy like it's
going chaotic i'd have a really positive
uh attitude and mindset about this
and i would be very receptive um
you know which is something you you
don't learn the the at very early stage
like if something is going crazy i would
like really go like you know but i
learned like it doesn't matter to be to
to get fear or to
fear a failure what matters it's
actually the decision that you take
and the
the decision making that you you're
doing i think it's important to have
this winning mindset it's like we're
gonna find a way to do it we're gonna
solve it
are we gonna get there it's gonna be
ugly and hard but we're gonna do it it's
really like a mindset mentality thing
that we should build
so i'd say it's a mindset and it's a
it's a it's a big big big validation
from users so
like you would never grew if we
didn't have the very first students
telling us that our service is good and
giving us feedback on what to improve
and iterate and you know
so i don't know this is my advice but
like there is a million uh in a sense
all this event is about having the
positive energy and the willingness to
take risks
and this is what is changing the
ecosystem for for the better
and i think like
if you're considering doing like
potentially risky stuff
there is no better moment to do it than
when you're young because it doesn't
matter like the fear of failure actually
grows through time uh you know i used to
work in a regular company and
when i left i left a senior position
all my friends said you are crazy to do
this it will never it will fail except i
actually had a lot of negative pressure
for my peers no they all want to work
for insta deep you know so that's the
funny thing but so believe in yourself
be positive because it's about the
journey as much as it is about the the
result if you enjoy the journey and have
a feeling you're doing exactly anything
you can and you're doing things that you
love you're competent etc
somehow
you know the result will end up more
likely than not pretty good but it's how
about the journey in a sense
and so uh and so yeah so i don't know
what you wanted to uh no
it's a good question
yeah obviously you know the uk is a very
sort of like pro-business uh
environment
very easy i remember setting up in sadiq
in the uk in one afternoon online it was
super fast
uh it's easier to raise money from
investors alike so definitely you know
there's still no comparison however i
believe tunisia is on the right path
startup act did help a lot already
and the key thing is we need to have big
successes in the entrepreneurial
ecosystem in tunisia such that the
government sees that hey this is
actually working i give you example
insta-dip was part of the startup act
now we are beyond it and now so we'll be
paying a lot of like social charges on
employees etc but because we have
accelerated and we're big business we're
very happy to pay your taxes you know
and so that's from the point of view of
society and the government this is
actually a success now you have a large
player who's actually contributing a lot
of tax
and so
i think
tunisia and the government there is a
good sense they start to understand
really well the potential of the
ecosystem but it is up to us
to prove that potential and and make it
happen and somehow uh justify their
trust in us yeah that's where we put it
so there's a gap
but
i don't think it's an issue to create a
startup indonesia anymore and you
definitely have to share your journey
like we like we started in tunisia and
then we incorporated in london you you
guys did a different path but a bit
similar so yeah we will communicate more
about how to do this
um
one last question yes
last question uh thank you guys for this
amazing talk uh very interesting
um
i'm a university professor in computer
science
i recently went into a new
adventure founding a new high-tech
company
in ai for e-health
where we're trying to prototype some
machine affordable machines for
auto self
diagnosis and stuff like this
well i'm trying to
uh with my colleagues
who are researchers i'm trying to hack
their mindset in order to not be
interested only in
publishing but also in
doing practical things
that can be helpful for people
so karim would you
give me some hints about how to interest
researchers
in order to
do
projects with
companies and startups and my second
questions as i'm trying to be inclusive
i know that
there's start to be a lot of
e-health companies in
in tunisia
so i'm wondering about
strategies how to establish a long-term
partnership
between
companies with the same
or offering the same products or
services
thank you
thanks for the question so uh
basically like how do you interest the
researchers into
getting their hands dirty and doing
stuff
well is by you do it first
essentially it's like if you want to
convince some of your team members that
something should be done and you feel
maybe they're not convinced
do it and show that it is worth it
and potentially that it is fun so at
instadeep we have
elite researchers we have really like
some of the smartest minds in africa and
and beyond
i we never forced them into going to do
a client project
we want them to be interested we saw
them hey we did all these things you
know like writing papers and stuff but
you could also like use that and have an
impact and they tend to like that and
likewise we let our engineering team
potentially participate into research
papers if someone really wants and says
look i really want to work on research
do this and that will make it happen so
it's about you show you lead by example
and you show it's fun and then
ultimately you know they will get
interested in this but yes i mean ai and
health there is
a lot going on it's a very interesting
field
it's also a heavily regulated field and
so this is an area also where you need
to be careful about what's possible and
not and not get slowed down the general
theme of health and ai is very
interesting
just make sure you minimize as we said
the regulatory footprint and engaging
with other companies etc
it should really be about like how
together
we push the ecosystem we ensure
new best practices of collaboration and
and the like and we push everybody up
essentially as we said it's about
enlarging the pie and doing things that
will inspire others it's a little bit
the same spirit we have yeah and i and
this is why we organized this event is
to really explaining that collaboration
can help
but be very focused about what you're
trying to do and try to minimize the
regulatory footprint
i think we're we'll go beyond three
hours so i'm gonna close it from here
yes so uh thank you so much for uh for
making it to this event yeah uh it was
really good to have you and hopefully
we're gonna try to throw more events
like this
and yeah i hope it was really
resourceful and like really inspiring
for you and see you soon
thank you
and uh we're gonna have a picture a
group picture yeah okay feel free to
come we're gonna have a group picture
oops
uh